pride month is officially over you can
hang up the rainbow flags and
leather vests and ball gags and whatever
else you're going to bring to your local
parade until next year or your local
elementary school or your local library
if the lgbt army gets their way great
pride month we overruled roe v wade we
expanded gun rights in new york we
expanded religious liberty at schools in
maine on football fields one thing we
always get in pride month are
corporations
trying to show their rainbow bonafides
by airing extremely woke commercials we
have a collection of the greatest pride
month woke commercials brought to you by
expressvpn more from them in a minute
first
the commercials
we
grow up thinking we're gonna be alone
we're not gonna find anyone like us
and then you realize it's not true i
love dressing up with my family
okay this is going to be
make apples and our platforms
our identities are all very different
that drives us i think to do the work
that we do
i'm so comfortable around these people
i'm very much my real entry self like
maybe a social media website or
something
family is the people who love you feel
accepted no matter who you love that
isn't true by the way that's not what
family is
h m
hm well it did have kind of cheap
colorful clothing i actually probably
should have gotten that it's not like
the procter and gamble ones where it's
just a short film about something
completely unrelated and then it's like
proctor and gamble
or you know they're doritos he said what
that didn't have anything to do with
doritos that one i i should have gotten
that one okay i'll try again
[Music]
you're saying you need to make your baby
gay every color
[Music]
i don't even know what that is but it is
gay the amazing thing with this
commercial too with all of these kinds
of narratives if you don't
pursue
your
sexual desires at any given time you'll
just be miserable have all the donuts in
the world
anyone who is married knows this anyone
who's in a long-term relationship
whether that be a
same-sex relationship or a more
traditional kind of relationship we
constantly are suppressing
all sorts of sexual desires why is it
that now we've got this narrative that
if at any given moment you're repressing
or suppressing or sublimating or
diverting any of your sexual desires
that you're just miserable in your life
is terrible i just i don't find that to
be the case do you not know happy single
people regardless of their sexual views
i know i know happy single people they
do just fine they seem okay there's more
to life man sex is important but there's
more to life than sex does it make sense
to you that the same company that
controls half of online retail also
passively eavesdrops on your private
conversations at home does that make
sense what about the idea that a single
company controls 90 of internet searches
runs your email service and gets to
track everything you do on your
smartphone big tech
is more powerful than most countries are
and they profit by exploiting your
personal data it's time to put a layer
of protection between your online
activity and big tech and that is why
you've got to check out expressvpn
think about how much of your life is on
the internet when you run expressvpn on
your device the software hides your ip
address which is something that bigtech
can use to personally identify you
expressvpn makes it much much harder to
trace and sell to advertisers i use
expressvpn on all my devices it's super
easy boom you click one button you're
online you don't need to worry about
people snooping on you all the time head
on over right now to expressvpn stop
handing your personal data over to the
big tech monopoly that minds your
activity and sells your info protect
yourself with the vpn that i trust
expressvpn.com
michael yt
to get three extra months for free okay
one more video i'm not doing very well
today
i think what inspires me
is other queer people
every time i'm feeling hopeless i
remember
that we're not supposed to be here and
we are
you're not supposed to be here what does
that mean queer and trans people are
everyday miracles
you're just people you mean your
everyday miracles
good grief it's so self-adulatory when i
was younger i did fight depression
find the outlet
that gives you joy for me i found many
times nature
sunshine
really just lifted a lot of heaviness
i feel heard
when people actually stop and listen
it's a very simple thing it's like a
photography company
i take care of my mental health by
consistently
checking in with myself and also with my
friends
and friends i feel really
like a phone company by then sort of
phone company you deserve to have a good
day today you deserve to have a good day
what does that mean you're a fallen
human being like all of us ugh the boot
company oh my gosh well you deserve to
have a good day what does that mean no
we are fallen human beings all of us we
deserve death
yes
there is hope we can look up and uh have
hope and salvation find god and open
ourselves up to the grace of god and all
of us all of us fallen sinners can
experience that miracle that's true but
we don't deserve it we're bad people man
it's just so ugh you're terribly
important
oh it's not even really a sex thing it's
this
culture of i'm i'm so great i'm so great
i'm the greatest i need to be i need to
celebrate me all the time
and i i'm so prideful because they
always say pride will give you joy not
that it goes before destruction and a
haughty spirit before a fall you know no
it just pride will give you joy it's
real it's really sad especially to see
people who've really mutilated
themselves and who are obviously in a
great deal of pain they're just
protesting a little bit too much aren't
they this i'm really joyful i'm really
living my best life i'm really
flourishing by making a big spectacle of
myself all the time i feel pretty and
witty and gay
as if gay people can't just wear normal
clothing it's very sad and it comes down
to this ideology of pride you can almost
entirely divorce sex from you can't
because we're sexual beings you know we
have a kind of sexual nature but you can
almost put the sex stuff to the side and
just focus on pride pride will make you
miserable focusing on yourself all the
time and me me me and i deserve this and
i'm so great and i'm so wonderful and
celebrating me it will make you
miserable a man wrapped up in himself
makes a very small package indeed it's
not that you need to think less of
yourself
you don't you don't you should have a
perfectly healthy
self-confidence and self-esteem focus on
something else man there's more stuff
out there
i can't believe i'm oh for three on
those commercials because they're not
they're not about the product at all
there's no it's just about this ideology
of pride which we've made it through
this year see you again next year
[Music]
[Music]
you